foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
video in the end game series now it has
been several months since the last video
came out and I know that everybody's
been very very patient but at the start
of the end game series I made the
promise that this time I won't
procrastinate and I won't abandon this
project until I've assembled a serious
database of endgame videos well it took
me a while I was tempted to
procrastinate I did but now I'm back on
track and these endgame videos are you
know the toughest videos that I make
because of the the research that they
require and the prep that they require
but I really really enjoy making them
and I'm glad that I'm continuing this
project and I hope you are too so this
is going to be the fourth video in our
pawn and game section we've talked so
far about past pawns uh Pawn races and
pawn breakthroughs you can find those
videos in my endgame playlist and the
wave that the endgame series as a whole
works is that you really should be
watching the videos in order so if you
haven't seen one of those videos you
should go ahead and watch that before
attempting to watch this one so you
might be listening to those titles and
say oh pawns pawns pawns what about the
king it's not just Pawn end games it's
king and pawn end games and so today we
will be taking on a very ambitious
challenge indeed we will be talking
about how to properly use your king in
King and pawn end games I'll be showing
you all of the techniques that you have
to know in order to optimize your king
use and to make sure that you not only
know how to operate your pawns and you
not only know techniques for breaking
through and for properly racing your
pawns but you also know where and how to
position your king even in complicated
Pawn end games so this is a very
ambitious task for one video we have a
lot to get through this video might
actually hit close to an hour I don't
know so my recommendation Brew yourself
you know your favorite cup of coffee
clear your desk turn your phone off you
know prepare to really focus because
this video is going to be packed with
stuff I hope it won't be overwhelming
I'll still try to go relatively slowly
but my recommendation is that you have a
board nearby you get ready to pause the
video uh because you know again there's
just going to be a lot of stuff both in
terms of definitions and in terms of
illustrations so the structure of this
video is going to be similar to the
previous endgame videos we will start
with definitions I'll introduce you to
nine themes Concepts topics that you
have to know in order to master King use
in Pawn end games and then we will have
the second section where I put these
Concepts to uh to the test and I show
you actual real life examples where
these concepts are successfully or as
we'll see unsuccessfully used by strong
players to win and sometimes to lose
upon end games so without further Ado
let us jump in
all right so let's start with
definitions and with King use especially
because there are nine terms it's really
important that you pay attention to this
section I'll be using these terms so so
often uh and so it's important to make
sure that we're all on the same page
even if you've heard uh these Concepts
and words a million times before you
know just make sure that you're you're
fully aware of all of the nuances behind
each definition that's going to make it
so much more efficient effective uh for
us to do the Practical examples
um okay so let's start with the total
rudiments the arguably the most
important uh concept related to King use
not just in bond end games but in end
games as a whole is opposition right if
you've played chess for more than two
weeks you have probably heard this term
bandied about opposition is a simple
concept it is a situation uh in which
the kings are staring at each other and
there is one square between them that's
literally all it is uh this is just a
typical example of opposition
and the kings are necessarily uh staring
at each other vertically there's
different types of oppositions we'll get
to that very shortly now okay you're
like well I get it why is opposition so
frequently talked about why is it so
important well it's actually easy to
understand why it's important the reason
it's important is well let's say that
white is the one who just stepped into
the opposition let's say that White's
King moved from F3 to E4 okay the kings
are in opposition what does that mean
well it's black to play
and the thing is black let's assume
black has no pawn moves black has to
move their King okay why is that
important well in pawn and games you're
normally trying to go toward your
opponent's side of the board and you
should already start to understand why
opposition is such a powerful tool
because whichever way the black king
moves if it moves to the right then it
opens up a pathway to the left and vice
versa if the black king moves to the
left then white king is able to
infiltrate on the right side of the
board finally if the king moves down uh
then you're giving white a choice of all
three directions so opposition is a very
powerful tool that allows you uh to
maximize your king activity and and put
your opponent in a situation where uh
where they have to yield a pathway for
your king
so this is direct opposition now there's
different forms of opposition uh by far
the most common type of opposition is
direct opposition the one you see in
front of you but you should be familiar
with the other types uh in particular
there is uh distant opposition or long
distance opposition uh that is vertical
opposition where there are three or five
squares between the Kings uh it's
literally the same thing as regular
opposition except there's more space
between the two kings and this is
important because assuming that you know
let's say it's black to move black will
probably have to move his King up at
some point and if he does then of course
white can step into regular opposition
so long distance opposition is uh you
know a often a means to an end and we'll
see a great application of long distance
opposition in the in the Practical
section then there is diagonal
opposition it's
just like regular opposition except the
kings are staring at each other
diagonally with one square uh between
them diagonal opposition is a lot less
important in the grand scheme of things
than regular opposition and much like
distant opposition it's often a means to
achieve regular opposition so for
example let's say that White's King has
stepped onto C3 the kings are in
diagonal opposition so oftentimes the
point of doing that is to lure black
into playing King D5 and now white steps
into regular opposition with King D3
okay so you should be mostly familiar
with the regular opposition you should
know that there's these different forms
of opposition that are found in the wild
okay
then we have
uh well actually we have a fourth uh
fourth example of opposition Which is
less commonly seen in books I don't
think this term really exists I call it
pawn assisted opposition so Pont
assisted opposition is a situation where
the Kings themselves are in opposition
but the square between them is occupied
by a pawn and you could think of this as
opposition on steroids because that only
is Black's King pushed away it's
actually pushed backward right in
regular opposition the king can go to
the side here the king actually has to
step back allowing White's King to step
forward and what you'll often see and
we'll look at an example that has this
very directly you can basically keep
repeating Pawn assisted opposition to
keep pushing the enemy King backward you
can go E5 and King E4 now if there are
no other pawns on the board then as you
might know this is actually a
theoretical drop
white is unable to win this game but
remember when we're talking about
definitions uh you shouldn't take this
literally you should assume that there
are other pawns on the board I'm just
trying to show the concept itself so
upon assisted opposition super powerful
tool and uh and and pretty common as
well so those are the four different
types of opposition now opposition in
and of itself is totally meaningless if
you don't also understand what zuzvong
is and sugsvong of course a German word
uh that I'm pretty sure comes from
zuguch's move and Swang I think means
trouble so literally it means move
trouble and zugs Wong is a situation uh
in which any move leads to uh harm of
your position any move leads to a
disadvantage now in the context of the
end game when I say that let's say black
is in zuk Swang what I mean most of the
time is that Annie move that black can
make loses the game it allows the
opponent to make progress in some way
that loses the game and another way that
you can think of zugzong is a situation
in which you would rather pass and give
the turn back to your opponent allow
your opponent to make two moves in a row
rather than making a move on your own
now in the middle game zuzvong is almost
non-existent there's a lot of pieces on
the board so normally you'd benefit from
making two moves in a row there are
examples of middle game zigzong that are
really fascinating maybe a topic for a
later video but in the end game because
your moves are limited uh and because
it's all about infiltrating with the
king zougsong is ridiculously common
almost every decisive pawn and game is
in some way decided by Zug Swan and in
front of you is a very simple example of
it so here white can make the move King
E4 incidentally stepping into opposition
and you can see the correlation between
opposition and Zug Swang King E4 puts
black in zugzvan the reason why is that
whichever direction the king steps onto
as we discussed the white Kang will step
in the opposite direction and in both
cases black is going to lose one of his
pawns either the C Pawn or the H1 so if
King F6 then King D5 and black will lose
the pawn race and if black goes the
other direction then white goes to the
right and picks up the h-bun winning the
game so I will refer to zuzong in
literally every example you know it's
incredibly important that you understand
that you frequently take opposition in
order to cause zugzang that's the way
that these two concepts are related
okay so that's Luke's mom on we go to
shouldering another very ubiquitous pawn
engine concept that you might have heard
of and shouldering is a process where
you use your king uh almost literally
with your shoulder to push the
opponent's king away uh in an
undesirable direction of the board
uh so the easiest way to illustrate this
is with an example it's actually hard to
provide a verbal definition so in front
of you is a very well-known theoretical
position believe it or not white is able
to win this position you might think
well even if black gives away the pawn
it's still a drop it's actually not a
drop so
what does y do in the initial position
as a matter of fact white can make a
bunch of different moves the most
clinical is to grab diagonal opposition
although that doesn't really matter it
doesn't matter that it's opposition you
can actually also play King D5 the point
is that after black makes a king move
black plays King F7 of course black does
not want to yield any ground and allow
White's King to go to F6 now you start
the shouldering process you go King D6
notice how your
that's the reason it's called
shouldering you're doing it sort of from
the side with your shoulder
uh Black's King has to move away and it
has to yield a square on the E file okay
then black will try to go King G7 we go
up to E7 same situation black is in
zugzang has to yield a square on the f
file on we go on we go until this
situation is reached the King has to
step back actually giving away the pawn
and it's worth noting that even though
black grabs opposition here this is a
winning position for white because the
pawn has reached the fifth ring so here
the king steps away King h8 G6 King G8
G7 and this is a very famous position
black has to go King F7 and white wins
the game with King H7 so
another thing that you should notice
here is that just because a side has
opposition right normally when a side
steps into the opposition it stands that
side stance to benefit but that's not
always the case right you shouldn't just
blindly grab opposition there's plenty
of examples where the side that steps
into opposition doesn't really gain
anything at all uh so you know
everything should be contextualized
within the actual position but this is
shouldering very important process that
allows you to win a lot of games
all right next we have the waiting move
or waiting moves awaiting moves as the
name suggests are pawn moves uh with the
express intent of putting the opponent
in zuk Swang so it's a pawn move that
does nothing except uh essentially wait
Waits your opponent out and and puts
your opponent in zuksong and frequently
in Pawn end games both sides will have a
a store of waiting moves like for
example white could have three waiting
moves black could have two winning moves
and we'll talk about this more in the
Practical segment but very often you
when you look at a position you want to
identify the amount of waiting moves
that each side has so here's a very
simple example
so it's white to move in this position
as you can already probably guess even
without calculating the best move is
King E4 stepping into opposition now
you'll notice that this is very similar
position to our illustration of zuzuong
itself pawns are in the same place
so the only difference is that I have
added a pair of a pawns okay how does
that impact the position well let's
think about this what does white want to
achieve well white wants to achieve this
situation with black to move white wants
to make black push his King but Black's
not going to push their King black has
waiting moves with the a pawn black
wants to do the same thing that white
wants to do black wants for white to be
in zukong for white to have to move his
game because if white has to move their
King then the Kings just dance around
King F4 King F6 and black is able to
achieve a draw so now we get this very
common waiting game where both sides
start exhausting and tapping into their
store of waiting moves in the side that
runs out of waiting moves last uh
induces zuk Swang slack is best advised
to play A6 A5 exhausts two waiting moves
at once and is a very bad idea white
will meet that move with A4 and black is
once again in Zuzu so after A6 pause the
video and make sure that you you
understand how white should respond
because a very very common mistake is
for a player to just sort of
absent-mindedly push the pawn two
squares A4 well that's very bad because
after A5 it's now White
who is in zuk zwang here I'm not using
zougs Wong to say that white is losing
I'm using zuzong to say that white has
lost the ability to win the game the
game actually ends in a draw because
neither side can make any progress
so instead white only exhausts one of
the waiting moves forces black to use
his last one and locks black into
zougsong with A4 so all of the moves
with the a pawns have been waiting moves
with the aim of putting black and
zuzvong which white has succeeded in
doing as you can see in this position
okay so then we have a concept that I
will not be talking about too
extensively in this video uh we will be
broaching it in more depth in uh the
subsequent videos where we actually talk
about really Advanced position positions
and it's the concept of triangulation so
triangulation is much like waiting moves
is a method whose aim is to put the
opponent in zugsvang and this you will
notice is a theme of Pawn end games as a
whole you do all this stuff and the
ultimate the end goal is often to force
your opponent's king to move away from a
certain square and give you access to a
decisive Square so
you can think of triangulation as a
method that achieves a certain position
with the other side to move so take a
look at this very well known position
which has occurred actually in a bunch
of different games
okay so it's white to play and you know
you should be disappointed to hear me
say that why because if it was black to
move then black would have to step away
with his King and white would infiltrate
B6 win the A6 pawn and win the game
easily so the moment you hear yourself
say that wait a second if I had this
same position with the other side to
move then I would be winning that is a
clear sign that you should think about
whether you have any waiting moves and
if you don't have any waiting moves
triangulation often comes to the rescue
so when you triangulate you make an odd
number of moves with your king in order
to create a situation where your
opponent has no choice but to reach the
same position with the other side to
move so white starts by playing King D5
that's literally the only move Black's
King has to step away and you're like
man I wish I could play King D5 to B6
now you might look and say wait a second
well I can go to D6 and this is winning
but it's actually not because if you
play C7 after King C6 black is
installment so the only winning method
is to get your king to B6
so now we start the triangulation we
drop the king back to C4
now again remember the moment black
steps to C7 you move the king up to C5
the goal has been achieved so Black's
not going to do that C7 is known as a
mind Square that's I think a term Mark
doretsky uh coined in his endgame manual
mind square is just a square that you
can't step onto because it will lead to
zugzvan so white has a corresponding
mind Square on C5 why doesn't white
doesn't want to step onto C5 because
then we're back where we started black
plays King C7 and here's the Crux of
triangulation you go around you go King
D4
okay again King C7 King C5 black has to
keep waiting and now we move the king up
to D5 and this is the rub because black
has to choose between going King C7 and
allowing the same position with black to
move or playing King d8 and now we get
this position previously we also had
this with white to move and that would
be a draw now it's black to move black
has to play King C8 C7 King B7 and King
D7 now the funny thing is after King A7
don't make a queen that still made the
fastest win is just to make a waiting
move with your king
um so you might be like wait I'm
confused like how did all this happen so
let's trace the actual path of the king
notice that the white king goes from D5
to C4 to D4 back to D5 in the shape of a
triangle and the reason I won't delve
too deeply into why triangulation
actually like Works mathematically we'll
save that for future videos just sort of
keep this uh abstractly in the back of
your mind and I think the Practical
example that I have to show you will
really help you contextualize is
understand how to actually apply it in
real games
okay so we have triangulation and
finally we have charting a course so
charting a course as the name suggests
is a process where you decide where you
ultimately want your king to be before
you get there right so it's like you're
plugging in your your final destination
into Google Maps and you're deciding
which freeway to take but first you want
to decide where you want to go in the
first place now
charting a course is one of the most
important things to do in Pawn end games
a lot of players get into a lot of
trouble because they sort of
indiscriminately assume that the King
has to go toward the center I see this
all the time now as you can understand
the center is a very important part of
the board and if you were to make a
statistical analysis you'd probably find
that more often than not uh the king
does belong in the center and upon end
games but that's not always the case the
King has to go to where the opposing
side's weaknesses are and it's important
to approach this question critically so
here you have a simple example if you
just sort of close your eyes and move
toward the center you're going to miss
an opportunity to win the game instead
if you properly chart a course you'll
see that black has a major weakness on
H5 and this weakness is accessible to
the white king what's the most efficient
way of attacking the pawn and H5 well
it's definitely not going through the
center right it's actually going through
the side you go King H2 and this wins
the game black is not in time to reach
the H5 fond black loses H5 and then
White's going to pick up F4 as well
incidentally this is a simple example of
shouldering right black
moves back to F6 and now you start
pushing black away using uh a type of
opposition this is horizontal opposition
which I didn't formally introduce as a
concept but you can see that all these
Concepts they often more often than not
they come together and you should be
prepared for each of the examples that I
am about to show you to contain more
than one concept right because in real
life you often have to use opposition
and zuzong and waiting moves all roll
together in one Pawn end game but I'm
gonna try to tease each concept out to
really show you how good end game
players are able to draw on their
knowledge of these individual uh
individual themes and Concepts to really
produce a masterful end game display so
those are uh the nine
concepts related to King use in Pawn end
games that you have to know let's run
through them very very quickly there is
regular opposition there is distant
opposition y
fast forward to this example distant
opposition there is diagonal opposition
there is
um there's zuzvon there's also Pawn
assisted opposition shouldering waiting
moves moves with your Pawn in order to
inducevang there's triangulation another
method of achieving Swan and then there
is charting a course with your king so
let's put these Concepts to the test
this is the fun part buckle your seat
belts folks because some of these
examples can be super simple others are
going to be really complicated but I'm
really happy with the material that I
chose some super exciting end games and
you know I think all of these are about
to have a lot of instructive value so
let's dig in
first example probably the simplest one
this does not come from a real game I
just sort of constructed this position a
good illustration of using simple
opposition in the wild to achieve
victories so White's trying to win the
game white is up a pawn and the first
thing that you have to determine in such
examples is whether you can just start
pushing your Pawn but if you calculate
okay G4 King C5 Black's King is
unfortunately in the Square Black's King
reaches F7 just in time so unfortunately
we have to use our King
and you would be forgiven for thinking
that you have to make a Mad Dash of the
king side in order to block black skank
from reaching F7 but this is where a
lack of understanding will really hurt
you because if you use that logic you're
going to play King C4 but King C4 allows
black to step into the opposition King
C6
I might say okay well but but I can go
King D4 and it's Black's not gonna go
King B5 right isn't the whole point of
opposition to do that Black's not going
to do that so the opposition doesn't
hurt white unfortunately it does the
opposition hurts white because White's
King is never going to be able to
infiltrate the fifth rank ever you know
the kings are just gonna dance and dance
and dance
and they're going to dance ad nauseam of
course whites King can move back and
that you know definitely doesn't help
now you might say well wait a minute in
this position I have a waiting move I
can now play G4 and then I can force
black to play King of sex and now I'm
the one stepping into the opposition but
as hopefully you already know and I will
have a video on
um theoretical pawn and games this is
unfortunately a draw because the pawn is
on the same file as the king the basic
rule is that the further along the pawn
is the worse it is for you right this is
a draw and if you're not totally
familiar that's okay
um I'd encourage you to set this up on a
board and just make sure you understand
why this position is drawn so back we go
to the initial position a student of the
end game who has mastered these nine
Concepts will know that the winning move
is in fact King B4 why does the one who
has to step into the opposition
now after King C6 again the point is not
to infiltrate to the side you have to
chase Black's King in opposition all the
way to the side of the board where the
pawn is at King D6 King D4 King E6 King
E4 King F6 and get 14 G6 one more time
and this is where
the actual infiltration happens right no
matter which way Black's King goes
you're going to step the other way the
ultimate goal of this procedure is what
I call unrolling the Red Carpet King G7
you can do the same thing one more time
opposition bang and look at this the red
carpet has been unrolled you can start
pushing your Pawn you can continue
pushing your Pawn after the King goes to
G8 again one more time opposition roll
that red carpet out G6 G7 and you're
gonna make a queen but the big takeaway
is that opposition
um is a repetitive concept right it's
not like you step into opposition and
that's it you often have to pursue the
opponent's king in a state of opposition
until you are actually ready to
infiltrate
okay now you might say well what about
long distance opposition that's a
confusing concept can you show me an
example of that absolutely this is a
famous study this is a invented position
this position was invented by again I'm
new stoddle I think German in 1890 I'm
always impressed when you know you got
these these guys in the 1800s coming up
with super instructive end games that we
can still learn from today
so the goal in this position is for
white to make a draw it is white to move
and draw so obviously pause the video uh
take some time to see if you can figure
out uh the only way for white to draw
I'm gonna sip some iced coffee and enjoy
myself watching you suffer
by the way credit where it's due I saw
this uh position in uh dretsky's in-game
manual uh so I would not have known this
position otherwise
okay
so black is up a pawn right and and
let's just understand this from a
general standpoint what would it mean
how can black win a position like this
well in order for black to win black
will have to win the F3 Pawn right
otherwise neither of Black's pawns is
ever going to be able to move forward
and in order for black to win the F3
Pawn black is going to have to shoulder
or knock whites King out of you know
these three squares
so you might look at this and say I get
it we need to get opposition and we're
just going to pursue Black's King in
opposition black will not be able to
make progress unfortunately things are
not so simple Watch What Happens Black
Goes King D2
you go King F2 black ghost King D3 you
go King F oh wait a second there's a pod
on F3 so we can't keep pursuing black in
opposition we have to either step back
allowing black to shoulder us with King
E3 and at this point you already know
the procedure one you know to the right
down and then whichever way white skin
goes black skin goes the opposite way
King G3 you go King F1 King G1 you take
the pawn right
familiar concept by now again King G2 or
King F2 White's King is now finally
forced out of its defensive stance black
takes the F Pawn and then promotes the
pun to a queen
so the F3 Pawn actually hurts white and
prevents white from continuing to grab
up positions similarly if white goes
King G3 then again black is the one who
claims opposition and then shoulders
whites King off of the F3 Pawn
so in order to draw this you need to
demonstrate a little bit more subtlety
and what you actually have to do is you
have to grab the long distance
opposition with the incredible move King
H1 this is the only drawing move which I
think is really really pretty
okay
so
so how does this how does this move work
well the point is that this is long
distance opposition there's three
squares between the two kings
and if Black Goes King E2 then we step
into regular opposition
I might say well wait didn't we just see
this position and I said this was a win
for black well what we actually saw is
this position we shifted the Kings once
one file to the left and this hurts
white because there's a pawn in the way
of the king if we shift it back to the
right then what you'll notice oh sorry
what you'll notice is that White's King
can continue to pursue Black's King in
opposition but should the black king
step in this direction you
correspondingly have to step back to the
right because if you don't do that if
you play King F2 well we've been here
already black plays King D3 if you play
King G2 you allow black to step into
opposition and shoulder you so you go
King H2
and you just keep pursuing Black's King
in long-term opposition the moment the
king steps to the e-file you step to the
corresponding opposition Square that's
it black can make absolutely zero
progress King E1 King G1 King D2 back to
H2 now there is one attempt that black
can make if we rewind all the way back
after King H1 black can try the move G4
and here it's very important to resist
the temptation to take the pawn black
will promote with check and win the game
instead you have the great defensive
resource King up to G2 now this
threatens to take the pawn and then the
pawns will promote simultaneously but if
black takes the pawn then White's King
is able to uh reach the E Pawn before uh
it's it's Visa V in black white is able
to draw the game
so this is a famous study and the
takeaway here is uh again that regular
opposition isn't some sort of Panacea
like you automatically grab opposition
in any case you have to actually look at
the position on the board and in this
case a long distance opposition is a
more effective defensive Tool uh because
of the way that the pawn is placed okay
all right so on we go to uh our next
example and this is another relatively
simple example that illustrates Pawn
assisted opposition so what's
interesting is I think this is a game
from the Under 12 World youth Chess
Championship the guy playing Black
Turkish uh Emery Khan he would later go
on to become a GM he's a very strong
Grandmaster now but this game was played
back when he was a little kid so it's
white to play and as per usual you know
pause the video uh see if you can figure
out what's going on in this position
who's playing for a win and and try to
figure out what you would do if you were
playing White
yeah
all right
so drawing on Knowledge from pre or
previous videos you might notice that
white is an advantage because Black's
pawns on the queen side are in a deep
freeze White's single Pawn is
controlling both the black spots now you
might then say well don't we have the
same thing in the center or Black's two
pawns are deep freezing White's three
pawns well no they're not right white
can't play E4 immediately but white can
use his King to help push that pawn
along and indeed the best move is King
D3 black has nothing that he can really
do so you play King E6 and E4 is a
classic Pawn breakthrough
uh and black sea is nothing better than
to trade all of the puns now what's
interesting is that a more resilient
defense for black would have been to
ignore would have been to make a waiting
move such as A6 white is still winning
here but the winning process is pretty
complicated it's a little bit outside
the scope of this video so for now we're
going to limit ourselves to the game
continuation black trades and trades and
gets this position I think black's logic
here was that white will be unable to
push the king away from the sixth Rank
and even the white as a past Pawn he
will be unable to make progress well
Mr Khan was wrong
I think it's pronounced Chun maybe I'm
okay I'm making I will not be a linguist
um so why was he wrong well the reason
has to do with Pawn assisted opposition
white plays the move D5 and even though
the kings are technically not themselves
in opposition I would still refer to
this position as an example of Pawn
assisted opposition in fact the pawn on
B4 is is fulfilling the role that would
be fulfilled uh with the white King on
D4 I.E it's controlling the square on C5
so the effect of this is the same as if
the white king had been on D4 and the
effect is that Black's King is pushed
back
now black has waiting moves but these
waiting moves are totally futile because
white can just go between D4 and E4
until black has exhausted all of the
waiting moves and so Emery decided not
to uh you know continue the agony he
goes King E7 King E5 and we repeat D6
again Pawn assisted opposition the pawn
controls the two squares on the seventh
rank forcing Black's King either
backward or to the side which then
allows white to infiltrate black played
G6 and white just Waits it out king D5
H5 H4 very efficient move freezing
blacks pawns and here Khan resigned
because after A6 white makes another
waning move forces the king back and now
the simplest win is to play King E6 King
E8 now very important technique make a
note of this even though it's not
directly you know a specified Concept in
the video the fastest way to win is
actually to stalemate the king but
you're not literally still admitting
anything you're stalemating it in the
sense that you're forcing act and now
start pushing his pawns and because of
the way the pawns are arranged
whichever Pawn blacks push it black will
push you will take it and open up a path
for another Pawn
and this in turn
will give white the ability to push his
own Pawn without worrying about
stalemate and White's Pawn promotes
first with Checkmate because the king is
on the eighth rank you can convince
yourself of this in this line or you can
make a rook if you'd like and the same
thing happens on the other side if black
plays A5 of course in such situations
you have to make sure that your Pawn
will actually promote first but here
White's Pawn does promote first so white
is able to win the game but here we can
see that the only way to actually make
progress in this position is to use Pawn
assisted opposition in order to push the
opposing King all the way back which
then allows allows you to win in one of
several ways
all right so next we have a a really
curious example I I really think a good
illustration of how dangerous it is to
relax uh in Pawn end games so many games
are lost because the player just thinks
ah you know there's two or three pawns
left everything is clear you know they
think they've calculated everything and
that's precisely when the blunder
happens
so in front of us is a very simple
position it's black to move in this
position black commits a terrible
terrible mistake now the easiest way to
draw the game with black would have been
to play The Natural movie for and white
would have had nothing better here than
to break through with G4 otherwise white
runs the risk of losing that this is a
protected past Pawn after G4 you have
sort of a mass liquidation and whatever
black can even play G3 and give the pawn
away
um as we've discussed because the pawn
is in front of the king this is an easy
theoretical draw and black doesn't even
black and go wherever
so this would have drawn the game but
black decided on a slightly cheekier
continuation black decides to take on F4
and I'm positive that his calculation
when this Falls okay my opponent has to
take with the King and who would take
with a Pawn on this situation and now
black has the very nice move H4 which
forces white uh to get a corner pawn and
as you know Corner Pawn is a draw no
matter where the kings are even without
the F Pawn even if you added Corner
pawns on all of these squares white
plays G4 then H takes G4 is also an easy
drop but the mistake he made is he made
an assumption you can never assume that
a move is bad just because it looks
unnatural right and here black assumed
that white is going to recapture with
the King but in fact white recaptures
with the pawn and this position is
winning for white because Black's King
is going to get inevitably shouldered
and because white has a very important
waiting move with his Pawn now black
also has a waiting move but
unfortunately black has two tasks to
take care of and he's only got one tempo
to do it so it's one or the other thing
okay so White's King wants to get to D5
in order to start shouldering black skin
so you might say okay let me beat white
to the punch go King E6 King D4 King D6
I've got opposition but is it a drug no
it's not this is where the waiting move
comes in handy white plays H4 putting
black in exactly the type of zoukzone we
discussed in the definition section the
King has to move back and at this point
you should know the drill shoulder
shoulder shoulder shoulder push the king
away win the F5 pawn and the rest is
going to be very easy
so that doesn't work out for black well
then you might say okay well let me
deprive white of his waiting move let me
play H4 myself well now the issue is
that you don't get to D6 in time and
white is able to reach C5 and once again
the shouldering process begins and white
wins the game so in the actual game yeah
in the actual game black played like
this white played H4 and one easily so
you know a great illustration of how a
very simple looking positions can be uh
can actually be very dangerous uh and
showing you know the importance of
considering all all recaptures all
candidate moves Pawn end games operate
by completely different rules you know
from in Middle games you can often make
certain assumptions and get away with
stuff in Pawn end games you really
really need to calculate everything
using sort of Brute Force calculation
okay
so of course you know that was a simple
example of shouldering shouldering can
get complicated when uh when there are
pawns on both sides of the board and
when you know the shouldering is
associated with both Kings kind of
starting to run around so what do I mean
by that well let's take a look at this
example which I really really like I
think it's super instructive it is white
to move and you should intuitively be
able to determine that because White's
King is a lot more active and further
Advanced White is the one trying to win
the game so you know the drill pause the
video If you really want to be serious
about it try to spend maybe a couple of
minutes uh moving pieces around the
board and see if you can figure out the
winning method for white there's
actually only one winning move here
okay
okay
so
when you look at this from a conceptual
standpoint you should notice a couple of
things you should notice that the kings
are in opposition and it is white to
move which normally means a disadvantage
does it mean that white is in zooang
know why because you should also have
noticed the white as a B Pawn what does
that mean that means white has waiting
moves so white can make a waiting move
and try to put black and zukes on so
if you picked up on uh the rule I shared
previously when you have waiting moves
normally you want to make uh as
economical of a move as possible if you
have two waiting moves you shouldn't
exhaust both of them at once if you can
avoid that so if you were choosing
between B4 and B3 and you were to do no
calculation at all you should still
Intuit that B3 has a higher chance of
success now I'm not advocating for that
but it turns out that B3 is in fact the
winning move whereas B4 allows black to
draw the game Let's understand why
the reason is that you know the second
waiting room is going to come in handy
white plays B3 now if black steps to the
left side then it's all very easy we
play King D6 then King E6 and we win all
the pawns that's you know that that
simple the hard part is figuring out
what to do after King D7 because you can
say well aha well now I infiltrate to
the left side but there's nothing on the
left sorry if there was like a Pawn on
A7 or something that would be one thing
but white will not be able to win this
game without either winning the C Pawn
while keeping the b-pawn alive or
finding some way uh to get to Black's
pawns on the king side
so
okay so what do we do now well there's
actually two ways to win the game
and the simplest the most elegant is to
now make the second waiting move this is
why you had to play B3 rather than
before at the start this puts black in
zugsvong again we can see opposition
being at the at the core at the center
of all these end games no pun intended
black has only one move stepping back to
D7 now we start to shoulder King B7
either black loses the pawn or after
King D6 you make your way to C8 this is
an amazing position it's zuzong again
black has a choice either you give up
the C Pawn the game is over or
you push C5 and if you look carefully
you'll notice that the simplest one BC
actually does win but B5 wins even
faster because White's Pawn promotes
with check remember from the pawn race
video identifying the checking Zone you
should have already noticed as soon as
Black's King was on D6 that a pawn race
was likely to be advantageous for white
because the pawn would promote with
check so notice the use of opposition
zugzvang and waiting moves and of course
shouldering which is really the main the
main theme of this of this example the
second one by the way is to immediately
play King B7 but this gets a lot more
complicated after King C5 so you're
welcome to figure this out on your own
but but the the elegant move uh the
clinical move rather is B4 in this
position
and then shouldering zuzong and again
when you have two waiting moves you
normally want to make only one if we had
made both of them at the same time if
you played before and if we get the same
position after King D6 this is where you
don't have that additional waiting move
and now it is white who is in zugzang
white has no choice but to just keep
pursuing you know the opposition uh by
the way if white plays King A6 great use
of long distance opposition no do not
play King C7 after King A7 it is white
who steps into the opposition and wins
instead you play King E6 long distance
opposition and keep pursuing White's
King King A8 King E8 the moment white
plays King B7 you play King D7 and white
doesn't have that extra waiting move
all right so now we're going to get to
um
a couple of more complicated examples
let me rewind this this one I really
really like because it is another just
phenomenal illustration of of the
importance of of waiting moves uh and
and the the importance of of
understanding how powerful they are how
impactful they are
so
we're looking at a position from an old
Soviet game my favorite source of uh
illustrative examples it is black to
move and once again because White's King
is so much more active black is the one
trying to hold the draw white as the one
trying to win the big question is where
should black move his King
b-a-c-8 C7 A8 only one square leads to a
draw the others lose see if you can
figure it out
okay so much like in uh the example with
the three pawns uh where black fell into
the shouldering Trap here olinsky does
something similar I think he didn't put
too much thought into this move because
it your hand is reaching for the C7
square like how can you not play King C7
who would step back to the eighth rank
deliberately right well a good end game
player would because a good end game
player understands that you know you
can't decide anything on a visual basis
in Pawn end games because the rules are
different after King C7 black loses in
very straightforward Fashion King C5
pursuing black in opposition and at this
point we infiltrated King C7 then King
E6 white easily wins the pawn race
and if King E7 white plays King C6
but this is not the end of the story you
might remember also from the pawn race
video that um one of the tips I I shared
is that you should you should always
test a defensive strategy that involves
pursuing the king if there's a corner
Pawn pursuing the king into the corner
and trying to lock the king up with your
own King and black can try to do that
here black and go King d8
and after King B7 King D7 King takes a
seven King C7 and he's got White's King
locked in jail King A8 King C8 but guess
what guess what well if you have been
paying attention then you would have
noticed that white has exactly one
waiting move and black has zero and this
waiting move comes in handy white plays
H5 putting black in opposition and in
zugs long if King C8 then white goes
King B6 and just runs the king to the
other side a black can't hold both at
the same time or if King C6
correspondingly King B8 and white
promotes to a queen
so this is how black lost the game now
let's rewind to the initial position
wouldn't it be great if black could
somehow get like this position but it
was white to move if it was white to
move here white would have to exhaust
his waiting move already here and then
the strategy of cornering White's King
might actually lead to success now how
can you engineer that scenario the only
way to engineer it is to play the
brilliant defensive move King B8 I guess
I should have flipped the board but you
know we're looking at most of these from
White's perspective anyway so hopefully
that's uh not to just actually let me
let me flip the board here
how does this work now at first it might
seem like this is even worse than King
C7 because you're giving white the
chance to step into C6
but the theme is the same it doesn't
matter where you're getting opposition
the eighth rank or the seventh rank the
upshot is the same the upshot is that
white cannot infiltrate any further
without exhausting his waiting move I
mean black is holding by a thread but
White's King
has no way forward and if the king steps
back then black keeps pursuing White's
King in opposition so at one point or
another white is going to have to play
H5 and now we adopt the lock strategy we
go King d8 King D7 King C7 and this is
where white needs that waiting move why
it doesn't have it anymore and black
achieves an easy draw because if white
plays A7 after King C7 it is white who's
lucky to make the draw white has to
start giving away all his pawns because
the king is stalemated and ultimately
this leads to stalemate uh so just I
think an amazing example of again you
know refraining from the natural move
and understanding that
sort of fully perceiving the dynamic
between the Kings is more important than
just making the move that's closest to
the center
and if you only take like one thing away
from this video the relationship between
zuzuang opposition and waiting moves
like those might be the big three uh in
in Pawn end games but King B8 such a
nice defensive move in order to force
white to exhaust his his last remaining
waiting move
okay so a couple of further examples uh
to illustrate uh the remaining themes
and I see this video has been going on
for 48 minutes I'm gonna try to keep
this to about an hour I know this is
long but you know I really just want to
get through all these examples uh to
hammer all these points home
so
um okay so this is from a title Tuesday
game that I played recently I had the
white pieces against uh David perovian
and this is another good illustration of
diagonal opposition and of shouldering
so in this situation my opponent plays
what looks like a very nonchalant move
he plays King F5
as it turns out this move loses the game
okay how does it lose the game as usual
pause the video see if you can figure it
out
now one thing that you should notice of
course is that both sides have a bunch
of waiting moves too to be specific both
sides have two waiting moves
so the win is yielded by F takes G4 King
takes G4 and King E4 of course my
opponent saw this and his logic was okay
I'm gonna go King G3
my opponent's gonna go like King D5 and
I'm going to win the pawn race but
Black's King is actually getting
shouldered and it's getting shouldered
with respect to the queen side a
scenario is ultimately going to unfold
after King F5 where Black's King is
going to be further away from the queen
side than White's King is and at this
point black cannot abandon the F Pawn
because white reaches the C pawn and
wins so black has to start exhausting
his waiting moves and after A6 hopefully
by now your hand is automatically
reaching for the A3 Square A4 actually
does end up winning the game as well
because here white has a waiting move
with his King but the clinical move of
course is A3 A5 A4 black is in zugz Wong
my opponent played F3 and after takes
takes King E5 I am able to reach the C
Pawn First
okay next example we haven't done a
triangulation illustration yet and once
again in subsequent videos we're going
to take a look at more complicated
examples of triangulation this is a
relatively simple one so it's white to
play
so White's got a deep freeze going on
the king side and white has a pawn
majority on the queen side clearly the
goal for white is to transform this Pawn
majority into a win how is white going
to break through well you can't play B6
because that simply gives away a pawn
and without B6 it looks like white can't
make any progress but Prince very strong
Dutch player multiple time Dutch
Champion finds a brilliant idea based on
a keen understanding of triangulation
rather than playing B6 he gives A6 check
looks counterproductive now you're
making it even harder for yourself to
play V6 but the point of A6 is to create
a square on A5 that you're going to try
to get your king to but how are you
going to do that black plays King C7
and hey if you play King B4 then black
is gonna go King B6 and all of a sudden
White's the one in zuk Swang and you
gotta allow Black's King to reach C5
but no no no white doesn't play King
before white triangulates with King C3
this forces Black's King off of C7
either you get this same position with
black to move enabling White's King to
infiltrate A5 or or black has to step
away and this allows the immediate win
with B6 the simple breakthrough and
white uh promotes the pawn to a queen so
in the game black saw nothing better
than to play King B6 game before King C7
King A5 and if the king steps away white
plays B6 as it turns out black has a
breakthrough with G5 and this does lead
to simultaneous promotion it does lead
to simultaneous promotion but it's still
a very easy win for white because white
is already up upon and after another
check Prince just basically takes the
rest of Black's pawns this is okay this
is a super easy win he takes all of
black spawns with check the queen end
game is a very easy win so it's very
simple rudimentary but you can see here
triangulation is not as complicated as
some people make it out to be just you
know you identify the position you want
to get okay if you don't have waiting
moves you can walk around the key square
with your king trying to get your
opponent uh force your opponent's king
into a lose-lose decision either you hit
the Mind square or you step away and
allow upon breakthrough for example
okay I've got two more examples to show
let's talk about charting a course
because that's the one concept that I
haven't really explicitly talked about
in the illustrations just yet so I
really like this example because it's
it's just such a good illustration of
how
white could have made uh been a lot more
successful if he had explicitly applied
this idea of charting the course
so in this position it is black to move
and black is right now up a pawn but
he's losing the pawn on the next move
that pawn cannot be defeated so lasak
finds an ingenious ID plays D3
classic deflection right Force the king
back and black charts a course where
does black chart of course too well as
I've said normally you want a head for
the biggest weakness not just blindly
toward the center of the board so black
doesn't just go King E6 black says well
White's only weakness White's only
undefended Pawn is H2 and so black
starts walking toward H3 and this is
where white responds on autopilot whites
as well Black's going to H3 I have to
defend that pawn so I'm gonna have to go
to G1 but white doesn't actually go
through the process of charting a course
what if white were to do the same thing
that black did where is Black's biggest
weakness what is Black's only vulnerable
Pawn well if you ask yourself that
question you're gonna realize that the
answer is F7 and so the only drawing
method would have been to chart a course
directly for the F7 pawn and the drawing
move here is King D4 only move
now there's a race black ghost King G4
white goes King E5 but it's not too hard
to calculate this at the end both sides
start taking each other's pawns black
starts eating first but it doesn't
matter because after King takes G3 King
takes G6 either you have total
liquidation or you have a pawn race
resulting in simultaneous promotion and
if you paid attention to the pawn race
video you would check quickly to make
sure that there are no skewers no no
nothing there's no funny business this
is a draw so King D4 it's as simple as
that in the game white plays King E3
allowing black skin to get to H3
and although white has defended you know
the biggest weakness White's King is way
too passive and black wins okay F6 isn't
even that necessary but in this position
black plays the very simple move H4
shattering White's Pawn chain and
forcing white after the trade to lose
the F4 Pawn black is just gonna go King
G4 King F4 white tries one last trick
the move F5 actually very ingenious
little move taking on F5 would be a
terrible move uh giving you doubled
pawns and white would use the outside
passer to make a draw so of course black
instead plays G5 and then calmly walks
up takes the pawn and this position is
very easy to convert
so charting a course the takeaway is
when you have you know a position like
this you don't just want to blindly head
in a random Direction with your king you
want to know where you're going before
you start and you want to evaluate the
various options sometimes you want to
chart a course uh that results in
passive defense sometimes that's the
only way but you always want to consider
an aggressive courses well what if I
counter-attack my opponent's weaknesses
and last but not least we have really
the cherry on top I could spend a long
time on this example but I'm really
going to tease out the most important
aspects because we are nearing an hour
and you know I know you guys are busy
uh so this position
occurred well it didn't quite occur this
is a slightly different variation on the
game uh this is an old game between two
pretty strong players actually the guy
playing Black Mongolian I am he was very
he's very well known for playing a uh
for being on the receiving end of a
brilliancy against Bobby Fischer uh you
should check that game out if you
haven't seen it just search Fisher miag
marsuran not the easiest name to
pronounce take a look at that game you
won't be sorry but he played other games
and here he is also on the losing side
it is white to move in this position and
again first thing you do is you hit the
main points whose King is more active
who's got the waiting moves you know
what's going on well obviously whites
King is more active and it's pretty easy
to determine that white has more waiting
moves
white spawn is on H3 which means that
black has an extra waiting move on the
king side but white has two waiting
moves on the queen side at least for the
time being black also might have another
waiting move if White's King leaves A5
so it's not totally clear who's got more
waiting moves both sides have a lot of
them so
we need to figure out how to make
progress with white and we need to chart
a course we need to figure out where to
go with our King well if you look very
carefully you'll notice that black has a
serious weakness on the E5 square if
white can get the king to E5 you will
then be able to infiltrate the entire
King side and so we chart a course we
start going there we play King B4 we're
going to D5 but we forgot
to understand how opposition factors
into all of this and King B4 is actually
a serious mistake that results in a draw
watch what happens after King before
here you allow Black's King to get
opposition King B6 the Kings dance
around to D6
and now we get a classic scenario of
mutual zook song where both sides
will now try to exhaust all of their
waiting moves uh such that it will be
the other side to move if white exhaust
is waiting mode first and it's white to
move this will be a draw because the
Kings will just start dancing but if
white can engineer a situation where
it's black to move and black has to move
his King then you know the drill either
white infiltrates to the right or to the
left and in both cases white is able to
win and so let's start telling why it
has to start making pawn moves so let's
say white plays H4
black plays G6
white plays G3 now once again you do not
want to exhaust two of your waiting
moves at once H5 is a terrible mistake
because if A3 not A4 a584 and black is
in zuk Swan so instead black draws with
H6
A3 A5 A4
and H5 and whites the one in zuksvong
now you can also try a very clever move
H5 you can play H5 yourself trying to
sabotage uh your opponent's waiting
moves G takes H5 A4 and you can say hey
I this works black isn't Zoom song
unfortunately this method almost never
works because black sacks the pawn back
in order to generate that extra waiting
move H4 GH H5 and again we have a draw
so the reason this fails is because
black is the one who steps into
opposition and wouldn't it be nice if we
got
this position but it was black to move
if we could get black to be the one to
start exhausting his waiting moves first
then we would have a chance to induce
zigzong how do we do that the way we do
that is we try to Spring a trap we try
to force black to allow white to be the
one to step into the opposition and the
way you do that is with the brilliant
move King A4
now you shouldn't be looking at this
movement saying I don't get it at all
the intention of this move should be
very clear you're trying to lure black
into playing King B6 now white steps
into the opposition we get the same
situation with black to move and I'm
going to go through this really fast
both sides start exhausting their pawn
moves blah blah blah H6 G3 H5 now white
plays A3 and it is black who is now in
zugspot
okay
but obviously black is not going to
cooperate black is nice I'm not going
King B I'm not letting you get into the
opposition I'm going to go King B7
and now you get this cat and mouse game
where both sides trying to get the other
to be the one to Flinch and this is
where we turn to long distance
opposition rather than playing King
before white plays King B3 now the kings
are in a standoff there is mind squares
all over the sixth rank the moment
either side puts their King on the sixth
rank you step into the opposition and
win
so we start doing a little Ring Around
the Rosie King C7 King C3 King D7 and
again it looks like White's not going to
be able to make any progress right but
with kings are just going to dance
around the seventh rank but notice that
pawn on A6 that pawn is very close to
White's King and this is where white
suddenly takes a sharp turn bang sharp
turn to the left what's the idea well
White's threatening King A5 right we
Shard of course we don't forget about
our opponent's biggest weaknesses black
has to defend that pawn with his King
and there is no way to do that other
than King C6 after King D16 A5 white
wins on the spot and after King C6 what
do we do well we go back to C4 and we've
gotten our Target position King D6 King
D4 and once again both sides start
exhausting their pawn moves their
waiting moves A5
um A3 by the way if black plays A4 then
white can just win by approaching the
pawn with the King black has to start
moving on the king side let's say H6 H4
you know the drill H5 G3 G6 and A4 with
zugspawn King C6 King A5 and it's
important or sorry King C6 actually the
best move is King C4 this is an easier
win because now after King D6 King B5
white is able to win the pawn race and
after King B16 King D5 you can actually
win this in several different ways you
can shoulder black skiing away and win
the a pawn or you can go toward the king
side
and the pawn race is going to be one by
white
because and this is a scenario that we
explored a lot in the pawn race video
white promotes and simultaneously stops
black from promoting as well so you know
I could have slowed down there but again
the key takeaway is is that opposition
really stands at the heart of all King
use in Pawn end games it's all about who
has the opposition who benefits from the
opposition and how do you use the
opposition uh to get to where you want
to go so we explored nine Concepts four
of which were different types of
oppositions we talked about zugzvong and
notice how intermingled intertwined
these concepts are the key takeaway is
that you want to always assess how many
waiting moves you have you don't want to
exhaust more than one waiting move at a
time you want to know where you're going
with your king before you start getting
there and you want to determine
how you know who is the one that wants
to usually you are the one who wants to
step into the opposition and I hope that
these examples you know as complicated
as some of them are really helped to
contextualize the tools and the concepts
that we talked about in the initial
section uh that was a whirlwind tour and
we have several more videos to make but
hopefully this gives you a better sense
of how to use your king in Pawn end
games once again we'll talk more about
triangulation we will explore a more
complicated forms of zuzvong in the
subsequent video so we'll have one more
uh sort of instructional conceptual
video and then we'll have one video
where we really put everything together
and and start exploring more complicated
themes well it's been over an hour I
know that's a lot of time for a YouTube
video I want to thank everybody for the
from the bottom of my heart if you sat
through the entire thing you know Round
of Applause to you thank you for making
the time and I hope it was worth your
while
so now we've covered ponds we've covered
the Kings we're moving uh in a positive
direction there will be more end game
videos coming out soon thank you
everybody for your patience hope you
enjoyed and uh I'll see you in the next
video very soon bye
[Music]